Our planet is home to a puzzle
involving chiral molecules.
These molecules come in two varieties
-both made up of the same atoms and bonds.
And even though they are mirror images...
they don't exactly match.
it's like trying to put a right-handed
glove onto your left hand.
Life on Earth is made up of groups of chiral molecules
that share just one handedness.
This is called HOMOCHIRALITY.
For example: the amino acids that make up
the proteins in our bodies are all left-handed.
Without any bias one way or the other,
chemical reactions will make equal amounts
of left and right-handed molecules.
But in order to make a group of homochiral molecules
the bias must already be there to begin with.
So, the source of the homechirality in biological systems
-the seed of this chiral bias-
is one of the deepest mysteries in chemistry.
Researchers think the solution might lie
in the balance of chiral molecules
in gas clouds in the interstellar medium.
That's the matter that exists between
the stars in our galaxy.
Scientists think that at one point the
balance must have tipped
in favor of one handedness over another.
But a chiral moecule has never been observed in space
until now.
Recently, scientists aimed radio
telescopes deep near the center of our
Milky Way galaxy at an interstellar cloud: Sagittarius B2.
Sure enough, they detected radio waves that bear the
fingerprints of the chiral molecule: propylene oxide.
This discovery is the first step in
seeing if chirality in space can explain
homochirality on earth.
Since it's thought that interstellar clouds
contain the raw ingredients
for the formation of our solar system,
studying the chiral molecules inside them
may even shed light on the origins of life itself.
The next step is for scientists to determine
if the propylene oxide molecules they've detected
are mostly righties or lefties.